hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the very
beginning of his work the categories
which is often assigned to students as
the first work that they encounter of
Aristotle's there is a very important
distinction that gets made as the first
topic of discussion and Aristotle goes
through it fairly quickly but we want to
dwell on it a bit and and use some
additional examples to try to drive home
what what's actually under discussion
here now this is a distinction between
three different ways in which terms can
be used or the way that he talks about
it as being named so what we're talking
about here are not a just on its own
although we'll come back to that in a
moment because that does enter into our
actual use of these sorts of things when
we say something is an equivocal term or
there's an equivocation on that term or
that it's ambiguous and we mean by that
that that it's equivocal in that sense
the distinction itself is going to be
between what we call UNIF achill terms
equivocal terms and what here in the
categories Aristotle is calling
derivative term
terms that are derived one from from the
other and I do want to point out that
because this is such a very important
distinction running throughout
Aristotle's works you're also going to
see this third category described and to
some degree developed in different ways
in other works so sometimes he'll talk
about it as analogous cotton hola Jeon
instead of being pero no ma sometimes
you will talk about it in terms of a
special kind of equity we're putting
aside any concerns or preoccupations
with that here so that we can
concentrate just on what's actually
being said in the categories because
they think that's probably enough to
take in at at one sitting so you notice
that we've got the Greek terms I
latinized the the letters but these is
the Greek vocabulary for it
so known so no Numa you know we get the
word synonymous from that right and that
is what we translate as UNIF achill
meaning that it has one one way of
talking about things right
the unif achill by the way is coming
from the Latin you know unum and and
voce
now equivocal homo homo Numa right
equiva City right from from the Latin
and this is the word that we get hominem
from and we'll come back to that notion
in a moment and then we have a power
onuma para is a greek term which means
sort of like beside or or you know next
to or it means a number of other things
as well
the way that many prepositions do and we
translate this as derivative because it
shows a relation of one thing stemming
from or deriving from another now you
notice that they always have this onuma
in there well that's the Greek term that
is used for name and it's also the term
that in Greek grammar at least classical
Greek grammar is used for noun and so
what we're talking about here are the
names
things that we could in some cases point
to it's not as if you can point to
knowledge inside somebody's head
although we use the word knowledge now
why is this distinction so important
well there are many cases where we're
using language in ways that we don't
realize we're not actually referring to
the same thing and we get into arguments
with each other so for example terms
like freedom may have a core meaning but
often times they are equivocal terms and
if we don't recognize the equity we can
go wrong in our reasoning about them and
we can get into arguments where we're in
effect talking past each other because
we're not actually talking about the
same thing let's start with what really
is in many respects the simplest concept
the UNIF achill thing so what we have
here is a name in common and then
Aristotle will go on to say they also
have the same and what we translate here
as statement of essence the Greek is you
know referring to a logos logos we're
translating here a statement can also
mean account description it's the word
that we get reason from all those
ologies you know those are coming from
logos
it also means speech so it's got a wide
range
it means argument - it's got a wide
range of meaning itself you can say
logos itself might be an equivocal term
or a derivative term but let's put that
reflection aside for a moment so does
the same statement of essence the same
logos tastes useiess Lucia is Lucy asked
then is is being or or essence or what
it is that makes the thing the thing so
if we think about for example these
various pieces of chalk in my hand they
all have the same Lucia they all have
the same
essence or being there that's why I can
change them one for the other it doesn't
matter which one I read on the
chalkboard with other than perhaps
they're getting a little bit small to
work with
likewise clothing you know tie shirt you
know whatever else a person happens to
be wearing those could all be understood
as being the same sort of thing insofar
as their clothes obviously a tie is not
the same thing as a shirt so it could be
differentiated in another way we'll come
back to the examples that he's talking
about in a moment because I want to
stress this this difference between you
nickel and equivocal so with equivocal
notice that there's something that they
share the name is in common here the
name is also in common here so that's
not what's differentiating them what is
differentiating them is that you're
using the name to talk about two or more
very different things they don't have
the same statement of essence they don't
have the same account
Aristotle will also use the word
definition Horace to talk about this not
in terms of like a dictionary definition
but a definition that actually states
what the thing is rather than just what
people talk about in you know the thing
being now this in in cases like this we
are using the same word to denote
different things so we have Aristotle's
example but I think it may be very
useful here to use some examples that
are a little bit closer to our own time
I mentioned freedom when people get in
arguments or another great example from
our own contemporary culture would be
choice right in political context you're
pro-choice that means that you're for
abortion or wait a second couldn't it
also mean that you're for charter
schools well now it depends on the
context doesn't it and so we get into
all these you know interesting battles
back and forth
well you're pro-choice over here but
you're not really pro-choice because
you're not for charter schools or
other educational alternatives or your
your pro school choice but you're not
really pro-choice because you're not for
you know a woman's right to choose to
have an abortion or not all right these
are very different understandings of
what it means to be pro-choice that is
to have that term predicated of
somebody's mindset or political
commitments or a program that they are
advocating we could go on and on and on
with lots of interesting examples like
that but let's use some examples that
are a bit a little bit less political
and closer to objects themselves because
being pro-choice or you know talking
about freedom that that's a little bit
of a abstraction the word seal this is
one that I use very often in teaching
this material what does seal mean well
one thing that it means is like on a bag
when you close it off that's a seal we
have a tight seal or the seal is letting
air in but it's also an animal the
animal that we see swimming around in
the ocean and doing cute things and
maybe you know if it's team playing the
horns or something along those lines
then again it can also mean a something
like a ring or or a stamp that you use
to seal something and it can even refer
to you know when we have a state or a
country or an office the the thing that
embossed thing that's the seal of the
President of the United States now those
are four different terms and two of them
seem to be derivative right the seal of
the President of the United States is
connected with that that stamping thing
and that stamping thing historically is
also connected with like sealing and
envelope so that perhaps is derivative
but to any of them have anything in
common whatsoever with the animal know
they they they don't have any statement
of essence of what it is that they are
that is common that is shared between
them so if you think that you're talking
about one but somebody else is actually
talking about the other one it's very
easy to get mixed up
there are many words that are equivocal
in that sense I mentioned that even the
term logos in Greek might be an
equivocal term because it has so many
different meanings perhaps they're
connected with each other though perhaps
they're more derivative but there are a
number of things you know Aristotle that
other points will point out you know the
the bone in our neck he calls that a key
but there's also the key that we use to
open up the door this would be an
example of equivocal terms you know we
run into things like this when we talk
with people who have a different dialect
and we find out that that a term that
we're used to using in one context means
something different in another you know
for example the term Fanny right here in
the United States that refers to one's
rear end and so we talk about a fanny
pack
for example now in Britain that means
something quite different and and so you
probably don't want to talk about your
fanny pack over there unless you want to
yeah you know have people be quite
confused and perhaps irritated with you
so that's a good example of equivocal
terms now let's talk about derivative
terms so when we have derivative terms
one term has the let's call it original
meaning although this might be relative
we could have terms that are derived
from a term and that another term is
derived from that term so perhaps we
don't always trace things back to their
their their origin but these have the
name in common kind of kind of the name
in common but they have a different
grammatical form so this is a little bit
easier to do in languages like classical
Greek than it is in English but it's
also possible to do in English so for
example this is another case that it
that Aristotle will use
in other places if we talk about health
right being healthy is a state of the
physical body we can also talk about
mental health too
that would be a derived term as well but
let's talk about physical health so we
say that a person is in a state of
health when every organ in their body is
functioning the way that it should and
they're not interfering with each other
and processes are going on as they
should and I'm not saying that that is
you know a perfect definition let's just
work with that for the time being now if
we use the term healthy we've changed
the grammatical form from health which
is a noun to an adjective healthy and we
might predicate that of say food this is
healthy food what do we mean in that
case we mean something like that
this will conduce to the state of health
or it will bring you back to the state
of health or it will prevent you from
leaving the state of health it's not the
state of health itself and if you
thought that it's that's what it means
then you'd get a bit confused and you
could go wrong and you're reasoning
about it no this is food that conduces
to health right another example that
aristotle uses is he talks about urine
because this was a common diagnostic
tool for physicians of his day remember
Aristotle's dad was actually a physician
and we can talk about somebody's urine
or you know they take we take their
blood more often you know somebody's
blood being healthy we what we mean
there is that that is indicative of
health it's not producing the health but
it is something that is rather a product
of the health that shows us that
somebody is indeed healthy so these are
all connected with some common meaning
some common system of meanings but it's
not exactly the same meaning but it's
not equal velocity either where the
terms have nothing in common with each
other whatsoever and many of the things
that are quite important
to discuss and think about fit into this
category of derivative terms now let's
look at the examples that Aristotle
actually uses I think it's always
helpful to look at his own examples as
well as bring up our own human and ox
can both be described by the word animal
that's not to say they're the same kind
of animal right humans are one kind of
animal oxen are another kind of animal
this isn't a metaphorical thing when you
call some big burly guy an ox that would
be an example of a derivative or an
equivocal term wouldn't it but in this
case we're saying that the human being
and the ox are both animals they both
fit under that rubric that term of
animal and we could go on and talk about
the statement of essence so animals you
know move around engage in certain
processes like you know eating
elimination sexual reproduction etc etc
etc right insofar as we consider them as
animals animal is a you nificant term
it's denoting the same thing so to work
whether we say human and mosquito this
would work whether we say ox and frog
this would work whether we say you know
snail and porpoise pick whatever you
like so long as it actually is an animal
that works this wouldn't work if we said
human being and amoeba and amoeba is a
different kind of life it is it has some
things in common with the animals it
seems like but I think we classify it
still as something different all right
let's look at equivocal now same sort of
example a human being is called an
animal and a portrait of a human being
is also called an animal a portrait as a
portrait of a human being which is an
animal but the portrait itself is not
animal right because it doesn't have the
same qualities and so if we're talking
about
portrait as animal we certainly don't
mean animal in the same sense that we do
and we're talking about an actually
existing human being so this is quite
interesting right we could come up with
all sorts of other examples contemporary
examples for for example you're watching
me on this video right now if you are
indeed watching this or at least hearing
my voice
could we predicate animal of the image
that you are currently seeing yes
because presumably there is an actual
person here at some point in time dr.
Sadler but my avatar or image or you
know maybe in the future hologram or
anything like that is not the same thing
not the same kind of thing as me even
though it resembles me and in many
respects we cannot use the term animal
in the same sense for derivative terms
aristotle actually gives us two examples
he talks about grammar and the
grammarian the person who knows grammar
grammar is a type of knowledge
grammarian is the person who possesses
and uses that type of knowledge courage
and courageous
Andreea in greek sometimes gets
translated in these books as hero it
heroism
although courage is probably closer
courage us right noun and adjective we
could also say he behaved courageously
right that would also be a derivative
term or he conjugated the verbs
grammatically that is according to the
the canons of grammar right that
wouldn't also be a derivative term so
these examples I think are quite useful
now you notice that with these examples
there are two terms being given so I
mentioned that we would talk about a
term itself as being UNIF achill or
equivocal what do we mean in those cases
because that will show up later on in
other thinkers and sometimes even an
Aristotle
if we say that a term by itself is unif
achill we mean that it really only has
one meaning and that all the things that
we would apply to that term of that term
to have the same meaning the same
essential meaning right if we say that a
term is equivocal what we are saying is
that there is an ambiguity there that
the term itself depending on what it is
being used of may mean something very
very different and in fact if we look at
the whole range of meanings of the term
for example seal as we used then it will
indeed have a number of different
unrelated non derivative meanings so
that is what Aristotle is talking about
is the very first thing in his
categories